the smashing, it's the rock and he's
playing this MMA former UFC champion
Mark Kirk.
>> MMA is it finds its roots in martial
arts. When I was training under the last
Grandmaster that I trained under, he
said, "Look at Jimmyi Hendris. Look at
Eric Clapton. The power that they get to
write and perform is the same power that
you and I tap into in martial arts." And
he starts talking about the Illuminati
and Freemasonry. and he's telling me
this is where the power comes from.
>> And I remember the instructor that I had
at the time, he demonstrated a painful
technique. He had gone out into the
woods. He had a training partner and it
wasn't a human training partner that
taught him the technique. Have you guys
ever seen the smashing Well, you
probably haven't seen it yet. The
smashing machine cuz it's just I think
it's going to come out in October.
>> I haven't even heard about it.
>> Haven't even heard about it. Don't know
anything about it. Yeah. So, it's the
Rock and he's playing this MMA uh former
UFC champion. I think he was UFC 14
heavyweight champion Mark Kirk.
>> Oh, so you're talking about it's a
portrayal of a real
>> it's based on a true real life story.
Okay.
>> I mean, the trailer is pretty intense.
If you've never watched UFC, I remember
watching it
>> when I was in my martial arts days. I
remember distinctly like the Gracie
family, how they used to dominate that
whole scene. Maybe you guys remember
watching UFC. Do you? Yeah, you probably
remember the Gracies, too. And
>> they really um brought jiujitsu into the
forefront of the public.
>> And it was after that then lots of
celebrities
started training in Brazilian jiu-jitsu
in their schools. I think they expanded
beyond Brazil into the US and they had
trained many many famous people um based
on their UFC days and so that's what
that's about and I just watching it the
thing about UFC if you've never seen it
before is it's pretty violent. It's
violent.
>> It's very violent.
>> Very brutal.
>> Now
>> and there's multiple other genres of
that like pride and there's multiple I
can't remember all the names of them.
>> Mark participated in those as well.
I remember watching though and and you
know my dad would talk about the UFC
fights. They don't have many rules, but
they do have two things that you're not
supposed to do. You're not supposed to
bite.
Okay. And you're not supposed to take
out an eyeball.
>> Mhm.
>> It reminds me of Holyfield and Mike
Tyson when Tyson bit him. And I know you
you laugh at that.
>> Yeah.
>> But when you're training in the martial
arts, there's no rules.
>> Yeah.
>> You get into a fight, there's no rules.
It's whatever you have to do to win. So,
if you have to bite somebody, you'll
bite somebody. You're trained. That's
part of your training. You bite them.
>> If you have to take out an eyeball, and
I mean like there's a technique to
remove your eye from its socket.
>> Oh, wow.
>> You'll do that to win,
>> you know? So, that's it. that I just
remember was a distinct memory like he
used to be like, "Well,
>> I could never fight in the UFC because I
wouldn't be able to bite and take out an
eyeball." I mean, like that's not a real
fight.
>> Yeah.
>> That's But that's shows you how violent
those things are. And I think
>> as a society, as a culture, we're just
moving there continually
>> and rapidly. And yeah, it's in our
entertainment. It's in reality, it's in
video games. It's in our music. It
everything is pushing us towards
violence.
>> Yeah. The sad thing is just the
desensitization of society. I mean, you
know, I'm sure video games play into
this, too. You see Fortnite, you know,
you shoot and kill somebody and you're
like dancing over their body. I mean,
it's like the fact that we're making
sport and enjoying and rooting on that
somebody like knocks his teeth out and,
you know, it's like
>> that's an interesting example. And what
I like to ask people, you know, if I'm
in an audience doing a a Q&A or or
talking about Fortnite is let's just
change the the goal a little bit. Yeah.
>> You know, let's let's say it's not these
random people. You have no idea who they
are. Let's just say it's a bunch of
little kids.
>> Yeah. Does that bother you?
>> Yeah, it does.
>> I mean, all you've done is change the
the people, the face, the form. That's
it.
>> Yeah.
>> And now it bothers you. What if you
change it to your family members?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, that's a good point.
>> I mean, does that bother you? And it
doesn't bother people start to be
uncomfortable.
>> Random stranger, they don't know. They
have no relationship, nothing like that
bothers them. I mean, it doesn't bother
them, but as soon as it's like a little
kid or a family member, bothers them.
And then, you know, you take it a step
further. What if the object of the game
is not killing people? What if it's
cheating on your spouse?
>> Mhm.
>> Now, where are we at?
>> Yeah.
>> Pornography.
>> Yep.
>> Same thing.
>> Yeah.
>> I want to show a clip here that will
kind of give us an idea of what we're
looking at that's happening in our
culture today.
>> Old time here. No doubt about it. They
both respond left and rights. How about
that
very
[Applause]
spectacular finish as
[Music]
>> this is just I don't understand this.
>> I'm from
>> what in the world is that? Yes, I just
started working um in bodybuilding and
pro wrestling shows and when the slap
fighting they reached me out um I was
thinking like this is a big deal
>> after slap fighting do you think?
>> No, I think it's all about the you know
your skills specific skills. I think
that everyone has their equal chance
[Music]
>> Matt Max.
[Applause]
Oh my god.
>> I mean, you got to be careful how you do
that, too, because you can rupture
somebody's eard drum if you
were to do it over their ear,
>> you know? I mean, just encouraging women
and smacking each other. I mean, it's
like, oh my, I just, you know, women are
designed to be soft and
>> Yeah. It's like
>> kind and
>> the Bible talks about that that in the
last days it's like Satan is turning
everything on its head.
>> Yeah.
>> Um Okay. So, we're seeing that the slap
fighting that's scary. And there was
other clips I wanted to show there's
women UFC. Um Oh, yeah.
>> But I just I couldn't do it. It's like
the the violence was so bad and then the
women are so inappropriately and
immodestly dressed and I just thought
we're not going to put that out there.
>> Right. You know how the Bible says, you
know, I'll set no evil thing before my
eye. And by beholding, we we're changed.
So, I can I can watch UFC or MMA or I
can watch professional sports where this
violence is taking place and I can say
I'm not doing that. But if I'm watching
it,
>> my body, the human brain, which you guys
revealed in pseudology, which is a
powerful documentary, I encourage
encourage everybody to watch that.
When your eyes are seeing something,
your mind interprets it as if you are
actually doing it. Yes.
>> And it releases the chemicals, the
hormones, the endorphins as if you were
doing it.
>> And I know we're not talking about this
on this show, but that's the same thing
with pornography. It's whenever you're
watching or if you're just watching a
romance movie and a man's committing
adultery or fornication, your body can't
tell the difference between them doing
it, you seeing it, and you doing it.
>> Yeah. You know, a lot of people um they
sort of just think that they can
separate out the good from the bad,
right? You know, like you hear that a
lot, like I can just take the good and I
can just leave the bad on the table. You
know, one of the things that also hits
me is if I'm sitting at the house, uh,
you know, in front of the television in
the living room or if I'm on my
computer, even if I'm watching
sports,
am I watching something that the Lord
Jesus Christ would sit here with me on
the couch and watch for an hour or two
hours?
>> Yeah.
>> I I had a guy email me the other day and
he said, you know, is this okay? Is this
okay? He gave me like a list of five
different things
>> and all of them were not of God,
>> but he said, "Is this wrong as a
Christian to do this?" And it was like I
prayed before I sent him a reply and I
said, "Jesus is about to return.
I don't feel comfortable spending two
hours doing something like this when
there's people on my in my neighborhood
that don't know Jesus is coming." I
mean, if there's people living where you
live and they don't know that Jesus is
coming, how can I waste two hours
playing a video game when there's people
that are going to perish?
>> Valid question.
>> One of the things that hits me too is is
am I am I promoting it by supporting it
with my money, when I buy a ticket, when
I go to the movies, when am I supporting
what is being portrayed or what is being
done? These guys that are getting head
injuries. Well, I mean, one thing that
Scotty said that that I always thought
was pretty powerful is, you know, going
to a movie and going to church is not
all that different.
>> Mhm.
>> There's a bunch of people in attendance.
You're listening to a message.
Essentially, a movie is like a sermon.
>> You pay to be there. So, it's like an
offering that's being collected.
>> You know, there's other, you know, just
similarities like that. And when you
think about it that way, you kind of
stop and pause and be like, "Oh, wow."
>> Yeah, that is I never thought of that.
>> What is
>> What is it that's going on here?
>> I think also from a spiritual standpoint
when you're looking at this, we're told
in the scriptures that the body is the
temple of God.
>> I was just thinking that.
>> And so if we're thinking about the
temple of God and the mind thinking
about the equivalent of being the most
holy place that houses the law of God.
Amen.
>> When you practice these sports,
>> you are doing damage
>> to the temple.
>> And you are destroying your capability
to appreciate spiritual things.
>> And then if that's the case, then does
it or does it not become a salvation
issue?
>> That's that's interesting. Anything that
impairs your ability to choose God
>> and to hear
>> to hear his voice and to obey him
>> that can become salvic.
>> Amen.
>> Yeah.
>> And fortunately, we serve a God who's
able to heal. So there are people they
make those choices early on and they may
come to a different realization later in
life and you know God is still merciful.
God is gracious. God will heal. It's not
that we subject we should subject
ourselves to those things willingly, but
if we find out on the back end that hey,
I didn't I didn't make the right choices
when I was younger.
>> It's not a reason to go out and do
something destructive because God can
heal, you know? It's like presumption.
That's presumption.
>> Exactly. Like it's a it's a if you've
made mistakes, you know.
>> Yeah. Right.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> You know, something that you all brought
up earlier which I thought was really
impactful. We asked the question whether
or not we're becoming more and more like
the ancient Romans and we're moving in
that direction. I would argue that we're
already here because something that the
Caesars did during that time was to
stage games throughout the entire year.
>> Yeah.
>> And then they would feed the crowds in
order to keep them in that festive mood.
And while that was happening, laws were
being passed that stripped away their
rights and gave more power to the
Caesars.
>> So when we look at what's happening in
the sporting world now, games year
around,
>> oh yeah, you can sports for every
season.
>> Every season, millions of dollars. And
then all of the businesses that are
attached to that to keep you occupied
while probation is closing out.
>> That's exactly right. To me, that is a
spiritual trap.
>> Yeah, it's true. Very true.
>> It's funny because they actually they
talk about this. Um, the Trumpet
magazine, listen to what they say. This
was in 2023.
They call this these violent delights.
>> The entertainment crazed Romans proved
that when distractions dominate, the
tough but vital business of sustaining
an empire is left undone. When 130
million Americans watched the Super Bowl
on January 30th of the year 2000, they
saw an ad for the upcoming epic
historical film called Gladiator. The
spot rapidly cut between footage of
colliding football players in an NFL
arena and the bloodied gladiators of the
Roman coliseum. that comparison between
the popular entertainment of ancient
Rome and that of modern America was more
apt than we may want to admit. And that
that's here's another article from The
Hill, which I know a lot of our our
viewers are familiar with The Hill. Uh
they say bread and circuses quote
unquote could strike down America like
it did Rome. The Oxford reference to the
the phrase bread and circuses provides
the following definition.
It is a term referring to the potential
of spectator sports and mass spectacle
to divert populations or factions of a
population away from the weightier
business of politics and society. That's
exactly what you just I was sitting here
and I was thinking, how did he see my
notes?
>> Yeah. Um, and then they go on to say,
can we find similarities between our our
current government's actions and those
of Roman political policy of bread and
circus during the waning years of the
Roman Empire. In a column for Bloomberg,
Alice Schroeder provides a list of of
specific conditions that existed during
the decline and fall of the Roman
Empire. And this is one of them.
Um, back a couple of years ago, we did a
program with a lady named Stephanie
Griffin, which I think she's been here
with you guys on Little Light Studios,
and and we were trying to put video
clips together to show what happens in
the UFC
>> and
>> tough.
>> I downloaded a bunch of them and then
Stephanie Griffin and I started going
through them and saying, "Can we can we
edit? Can we cut?" and and the Lord just
convicted me. Eric, don't show the video
clip. So, I took a picture, a
screenshot, and I want you to look at
these guys, these two men, their faces.
>> Look at it. Is
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And you can already tell that
their ears have been affected by many
damages to the side.
>> I mean, you look at this one ear.
>> Yeah. And that's that's common even in
in jiu-jitsu. Yes. In Kodakon judo, in
boxing and in Brazilian jiu-jitsu.
>> And is that like a like a like a rights
of passage like a pride of like
>> Well, it just means your ears. It's not
just from the hit. It's from the rolling
around on the ground and the grappling.
>> And it is a badge.
>> Yeah. Badge. That's the word I was
thinking of. You know what I mean? Badge
of honor.
>> Yeah.
>> Listen to listen to what our father in
heaven what the Lord tells us. He says,
"It repented the Lord that he had made
man on the earth, and it grieved him at
his heart, for the earth also was
corrupt before God, and the earth was
filled with violence." You know, all
through the gospels in Matthew 24, Luke
21, Jesus says, "As it was in the days
of Noah, so shall it be in the days when
the son of man returns." Mhm.
>> You know, this is a really um it's eye
opening and it's painful to see because
what we've seen in the area of sports
and martial arts in particular is an
evolution in martial arts. Now, we came
up during the time of traditional arts.
>> All right? And there was hard training,
there was sparring, etc.
But what has happened since 1993
with the advent of the UFC, for example,
is that with the coming of the Gracie
family introducing effective grappling
style, for the first time in our martial
arts history, you had people coming
together to see what works and what
doesn't. And what you have now is a
wider knowledge of the most effective
techniques from the different styles
>> and children are coming up with this
knowledge.
>> Mhm.
>> And so you have children who are
training in techniques and in
methodologies that we never learned.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's part of their DNA if they come
up. So, they're more apt at the violence
than we ever were.
>> Do you know? And Scotty, do you
remember, and I know Keith, you probably
do, in the Dragon Revealed, I don't
remember if it was in part one or part
two, which both of those will include a
link in in the drop down box under this
video, but there was a film clip where
it showed this little boy with his dad
or his instructor, and he's doing these
techniques with the boxing gloves on.
He's got the head gear and he's fighting
and the dad is showing him how to
grapple, how to do the MMA. And this is
a little boy. He couldn't have been six
or seven, maybe eight years old at
maximum.
>> He looked good, didn't he? His
techniques probably sharp.
>> Uh well, he was a relative by marriage
and no longer married to my my aunt. But
uh he came from a martial arts family.
Grew up he gold medalled in um the
Goodwill Games in Calgary in like 1998
1988.
And um his dad Ray Dulki had several
studios in Southern California for
Shakon Karate used to form his fists in
the crib
>> and was like start you know the the I
mean it was like from a baby.
>> Wow. And you know, he he he probably
could have won more, but he was
disqualified, I think, several times,
you know, for things that that happened
while he was is in it. But yeah, some
people sad
>> really early.
>> Yes.
>> Uh really early. But the other thing
that strikes me about that passage of
scripture is the Bible says the thoughts
of their heart were only evil.
Continually. Mhm.
>> So man is just in this evil mindset all
the time and out out of that the result
of that
>> violence.
>> Yes.
>> And you think about that our music our
Hollywood our television if you say well
I don't have Hollywood are you watching
stuff on YouTube
>> right?
>> Um what are we reading? It's like our
mind is constantly the enemy is saying
I'm going to put these people who claim
to be gods and that God claims as his
own. I'm gonna change them into my
image.
>> Yeah. Right.
>> I mean, I don't know what's more
disturbing like going to a a war film
and sitting there eating popcorn and
candy and you know, watching people like
lives being ended. Like, think about
that. The history of the world. Nobody's
nobody I mean maybe people went in
spectator watched the battle being
happening, right? But but I mean like
you if you went through a war like that
and especially that up close and
personal something like Vietnam I mean
you came back different.
>> Yes.
>> And yet we in our society have no
problem sitting down and watching this
like it's like popcorn
>> entertainment
>> entertainment. There was, I think, a
couple of films
that I think prepared the way for some
of this.
>> Blood Sport,
>> you know, Jean Clad Vanam.
>> And also there was a there was a I don't
remember if it was a trilogy or if there
was four in the series. I think there
was four,
>> the best of the best.
>> Yes.
>> Do you remember that? Yes. That film
series. And it was very much like this
UFC style cage fighting thing where
people are essentially fighting to the
death and
other people to watch and enjoy and bet
on and all of this. It's it's pretty
crazy like you said that we find
enjoyment.
>> Yes.
>> In something like natural. And what
started the the seed of those movies was
actually Enter the Dragon, the opening
scene with Bruce Lee because it was so
popular back in 1973 when it came out
because he was blending the styles. He
had the same shorts, he had the same
gloves and they patterned
>> um the UFC garb off of that gloves
>> and then they created the octagon off of
Chuck Norris's movie. I think it was the
octagon.
>> Wow. Mhm.
>> And so that that's the the the basis of
the
>> several things that fed into where we're
at today.
>> And you really wonder like you know like
does the devil say I want to go here
with society down the road? I mean, he's
obviously seen this like, you know, from
the bread and circus days way back when
and the gladiator days and and it's
like, is he planting these things in
movies to to push society down that road
or are we just like getting these sick
ideas from each other?
>> Let me I'm just going to throw a
thought. This is just a what if.
In one of our earlier programs, Keith
talked about the fact that there's two
battles. There's a physical battle and
there's a spiritual battle, a war that's
taking place.
The Bible throughout the book of
Revelation tells us that at the end, at
the very end of this world,
Satan is going to gather all the wicked
together in order to fight against the
Lord Jesus Christ.
And you think that's crazy. The Bible
says so.
>> That's right.
>> It's a physical battle.
>> It's a physical battle. spiritual battle
but
>> but the people that he is calling to as
his army are possessed by demons.
>> Yeah.
>> So it is physical and spiritual.
>> So is Satan preparing his army now? Yes.
Is God preparing his army now? Yes.
>> Yeah. I mean, he's planting the idea
like you look at Endgame or whatever and
when they're all rushing towards this
like thing in the end and they're all
this like battle and it's like, you
know, for the end of the world or
whatever like this, right? There is
going to be a moment like that. You go
read Revelation 20. I mean, you know,
verses 1-7, it tells you when Satan's
loose from his prison that that there's
going to be a battle that's going to
ensue and that's when the fire comes
down from heaven. You know, that's the
city of Jerusalem coming down and
Satan's like, "There's more of us than
there's of them. Let's take them." Yeah.
>> You know, and
>> so is he putting is he program
>> I think he's planting that seed now.
>> He's programming us.
>> So he's getting Wow, that's incredible.
So
he is doing everything that he can do to
one damage the most holy place so you
can't ingrain spiritual things but at
the same time he wants you to have that
>> mental mindset that we talked about in
the last program of sizing people up
being violent prone and ready to attack
and react
>> and the result of that we see it
regularly in the news. I mean, you think
about what happened with Charlie Kirk.
We're at the place in society, you don't
agree with somebody, take him out.
>> Yeah.
>> Publicly.
Do y'all remember, and I know you will,
do you remember in the Matrix
>> when Neo is awakened and he starts
coming back, they say, "We got to train
you." M
>> and they plug him in
>> and download kung fu, MMA, and
>> download how to shoot and how to kill
and how to defend.
>> Yeah, it's true.
>> We are doing the same thing through
media.
>> That's interesting.
>> Even though we don't have a cord coming
out of our head plugging in, it's
happening through the eyes.
>> That's true.
>> We are being we're downloading
information. So then this scripture that
we just read for the earth also was
corrupt before God and the earth was
filled with violence. But you mentioned
earlier part of that was
>> the thoughts of human beings was only
evil continually. Could that be because
even back in the anti-delivian days
Satan made violence so palatable so
enjoyable
>> that it was always on the thoughts.
>> Yeah. This is just a picture of the
preliminaries be before a UFC or MMA
fight. And I want you just to notice
some things about the images.
>> If you look at the at the the referee or
whoever that's standing in in the
middle, does he look like he's happy?
Does he look like somebody you'd want to
watch your children or your
grandchildren?
>> I mean, I'm serious.
>> He's not my first choice for a
babysitter. What about the two men that
are about to face off against each
other?
>> You can tell that they're definitely
looking down on each other
>> and there's there's pride.
>> Mhm.
>> Um, and do you know what's scary? A lot
of times, and I'm just going to tell you
this as a man, men, because of the
culture, we have been put into a
position where we grow up feeling like
we need to prove ourselves.
>> Yes.
>> And and so when you meet another man,
you're like, I've got to prove that I'm
equal with him or better. I've got to
prove myself. Women do the same thing.
Am I as pretty as she is? I've got to,
you know, I met this woman last week at
church and now I've got to up the way
that I'm dressing because I want to be
equal. I want to be I want to be seen as
important. I want to be seen as
valuable. That I have purpose.
>> You look at the two women and, you know,
they're not they're not modestly
dressed. You look at the expressions on
their faces. Um, all of this is a
culture that's being developed. It's
being programmed that does not show the
character of Christ, but shows the
character of Satan.
>> But what this is portraying to the
audience
mistakenly is strength.
>> Yeah.
>> Strength and the approval of beautiful
women. So, it's something that the men
can aspire to.
>> That's a good point.
>> It's super true. That's why they put
those women in there.
>> And that's why you've got the card girl.
I remember the first uh the first huge
full contact uh tournament I went to. It
was a kickboxing. I'd never been to
something this big. It was a national
and I get there and there's 5,000 people
in the in the arena and I was like a
nervous wreck. I was like, "What in the
world am I doing?" Being in front of 50
people was nervous. There's 5,000 people
there. And then these girls come out in
these bikinis with, you know, the card
girl holding up, you know, the round
numbers. And I'm like, and you know, and
then it's like pride comes in. I've got
to perform. I've got to, you know,
portray myself a certain way. The Bible
says by their fruits,
you shall know them.
>> You know a tree by what kind of fruit
it's producing. And you know, it's funny
because if you're an apple tree, it
doesn't matter how bad you try, you
can't produce oranges or mangoes or
avocados.
>> The tree, the roots of the tree have to
be completely changed in order to change
the fruit.
>> And as a human being, that's the same
way. I can say, "Okay, you know, Little
Light Studios or Eric or or Christian or
Scotty or Keith, they're telling me I
don't need to watch this stuff, but I
want to." That shows us the condition
that needs to be changed. It's our
hearts that have to be changed. Because
when your heart is changed by the spirit
of God, all of a sudden you don't enjoy
the things that you used to enjoy and
you start loving the things that used to
be unappealing to you. That is such an
important point because what it's saying
then is that our society because
>> we're moving further and further away
from God and towards loving the
violence, it means that at the very core
of our society and what we're taking in,
it's it's it's evil.
>> Yeah.
>> The root is evil and unless it's
changed. So, a fascinating follow-up to
this is Jesus is is saying in Matthew
7:20, "By their fruits, you will know
them." Immediately after this, he starts
describing a group of Christians in the
last days.
>> And what his point is,
their actions
don't match their words.
>> So, when he says, "By their fruits, you
will know them." He's like, "Look, the
actions
>> they they have to be there."
>> Yes. If they're not there, I know
there's nothing there. This is what
Christ is saying. So in the in the last
days, it talks about just right after
this in Matthew 7 that there's going to
be a people who are saying, "Lord,
they're Christians. They're ident
they're identifying Jesus as Lord and
they're still lost because he said
you're practicing lawlessness. You
didn't do what I asked you. You did what
you thought needed to be done, but not
what I asked you to do."
>> Yeah.
scary place.
>> You're practicing lawlessness. And what
is the law? I mean, it's like your
relationship with other people, right?
Yes.
>> I mean, where in the law commands?
>> Yeah. Where in the law of God does it
ever say, "I'm going to smash your face
in,
>> knock your teeth out." You know, it's
like
>> we're to be loving on each other.
>> I mean, really selfless loving on each
other is the way heaven operates. really
fascinating scripture I came across when
I was studying the life of Solomon
because I was comparing it to the life
of Jesus and Solomon didn't make all the
right choices.
Um we say that knowing he was you know
the smartest guy in the world um at
least at his time.
But when you look at the life of Jesus
in in um Isaiah 7:15 it says curds and
honey shall he eat that he may know to
refuse the evil and choose the good.
Amen.
>> So, every little detail of Christ's life
was important. Like even his diet was
important so that he would know how to
choose what's good and refuse evil. So,
how much more important are little
details in our lives to help us make the
right choices.
>> Amen. Here's another two verses from
Psalms. And you'll see over on the right
hand side there's a UFC uh versus pride
which is another combative sports uh
>> I don't know what you would call it
another arena that people can you know
participate in this
>> cage fighting another organization.
>> Yeah.
>> In Psalms 10:2 it says the wicked
through the pride of his countenance
will not seek after God.
>> God is not in all his thoughts.
Therefore, pride compasseth them about
as a chain. And you look at what this
man in the in the portrayal is wearing
around his neck.
>> A chain.
>> Pride compass them about as a chain, and
violence coverth them as a garment. I
now I'm not judging these men because I
was there. I mean, like, there's none of
us that are any better than one another.
Every one of us, if we haven't done it,
we've thought it.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I'm not judging these men, but what
I'm what I'm saying is as a Christian,
>> I want to pray for these men. I mean,
like literally, if you're watching this
right now, start lifting these men and
these women up in prayer. Ask the Lord,
open their eyes so that they can see
what God created them for, the high the
high destiny that they have as children
of God. You know, I look at like when I
was growing up, um, there was two
probably men that were really really
well known for their their physique,
>> right?
>> Arnold Schwarzenegger and Lou Frigno,
who played the Incredible Hulk. I mean,
those were the guys that you were like,
man, you know, Arnold Schwarzenegger, he
was he was a top athlete.
But in the resurrection,
when Arnold Schwarzenegger comes up out
of the grave
and Adam, the son of Almighty God, is
standing there beside him, do you know
what Arnold Schwarzenegger is going to
think?
>> He's going to be like ashamed of his
physique.
>> What about the most gorgeous woman that
we think Beyonce or Christina Aguilera
or whoever Madonna whatever we think
they're all that hot? What is she going
to think when she comes up beside Eve,
the first woman, who is now clothed in
that glory that God designed us to have?
>> So, I'm like, I don't want to be this. I
want to be what God designed us to be.
>> Amen. you know, and I think that what
you just said about praying for a lot of
these fighters, I'll tell you, I've
spoken to some of them and um
some of the coolest guys you could meet,
you know, when you we speak with them
and when you get to know their stories,
they're putting many of them are putting
their bodies through this out of love
for their families. Mhm.
>> Um many of them know that they're not
going to go into the corporate world,
etc. So, they see this as a way to make
some good money, to strive to give their
families a better life, and they know
that they're impairing their health in
order to do it. So, the aim is noble.
It's just that the way that it's being
that that they're pursuing it is
jeopardizing them in the long term. And
many of them don't see the spiritual
part of this. And uh that's where my
heart goes out uh to these gentlemen.
>> Well, let let's do let's lift everybody
in prayer. when you're seeing Hollywood
actors or musicians, instead of us just
criticizing them, let's be critical or
think about the actions, but let's pray
for the person because Jesus wants to
save them as bad as he wants to save
each of us.
>> Amen.
>> I want to show another clip here from
the dragon revealed, and this is from
the second film. A Christian instructor
joined to a pagan style is spiritual
adultery, unfaithfulness, and apostasy.
>> I'm 100% Jesus. God can see my heart.
People misunderstood think, "Oh, how a
Christian can fight MMA."
>> Oh, and now goes for the triangle show.
>> Yeah, for sure. A Christian can fight
MMA. A Christian can go to a war. A
Christian can go We Christians, we're
not different. We're just Christians.
And I don't see nothing wrong in that.
But do these thoughts agree with the
word of the living God? And if this is
correct, then why does the Lord tell us
through his apostle John that he which
saith he abideth in Christ ought himself
also so to walk and live even as Jesus
lived. They call themselves warriors,
literally fighting the good fight of
faith. Never mind that the Gospel of
Matthew quotes Jesus as saying, "If
anyone slaps you on the right cheek,
turn to him the other also." Because
tonight you're going to meet a group of
Christians who say that by striking an
opponent, well, they're striking a blow
for the Lord. Ryan Owens has an encore
presentation from our series Faith
Matters.
[Applause]
[Music]
>> Fight breaks out.
But this isn't your grandfather's bar
fight.
>> Hurt like a Then as soon as I take you,
let's pray.
>> And some of these fighters give Bible
beaters.
>> Father, we just uh thank you for the
opportunity to go out tonight and to
train and compete and
>> a whole new meaning. The line of
distinction between professed Christians
and the ungodly is now hardly
distinguishable. As Christians, there
are times where you take shots.
That's where the Bible gives you your
training.
[Music]
I get all the time, I don't look like
the typical pastor. And that's okay.
There's actually a cool verse in the
Bible. It says, "Be weary when all men
speak well of you. If everybody loves
you, you're doing something wrong.
>> God, you have called us to a fight."
When Preston came up with the idea of
having a fight club in the church, it
was an easy thing to say yes to.
>> Tough guys need Jesus, too.
>> You guys like to see me fight another
pastor? We'll just be a couple of
god-fearing men punching each other in
the face.
>> Ladies and gentlemen, this is pastor
versus pastor.
>> Tonight, we got to fight and then we'll
talk about Jesus tomorrow when we go to
church.
The first thing that caught my attention
was will when that Brazilian jiu-jitsu
instructor said, "Of course a Christian
can do MMA. Of course, a Christian can
do this and do this." And he said,
"After all, we're just Christians. We're
not different." And it was like the
alarms just went off because I was like,
"The entire Bible says we're supposed to
be different than the world."
>> You know, what fellowship does light
have with darkness?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I think it's it's it's sad
to not just recognize that the very
thing that you're trying I mean, how do
you how would you separate out like
let's go out and love your enemy and
let's do good to those that hate you.
And you know, the concepts that the
Bible is trying to teach you is is this
just, you know, laying down your life so
that someone else can have a better
existence. You know, it's like that's
just the that's just the ultimate
demonstration of love, right? The Bible
says about that very thing you just
brought up, but you are a chosen
generation, a royal priesthood, a holy
nation, his own special people,
>> that you may that you may proclaim the
praises of him who called you out of
darkness into his marvelous light, who
once were not a people, but are now the
people of God, who had not obtained
mercy, but now have obtained mercy.
>> Amen. That right there shows us that God
is saying you're that's what it means to
be holy
>> to be separated.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think about how the children of
Israel reverenced the temple.
>> Amen.
>> And when I look at that and realize that
they're training to strike and to tear
down and to destroy the temple
physically.
>> Wow. the the the the representation
there is totally contrary to what the
scripture teaches.
>> That's a good point. Yeah, that's
confusion.
>> Yes,
>> it is.
>> Yeah.
>> And the thing is is it's like, okay, so
the this is not self-defense.
>> No,
>> this is sport.
>> Yeah.
>> And then you've got pastors that are
doing this and
>> the heart has to be changed.
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> because to even desire that, you know,
like like that one the news broadcaster
who's not even a a Christian. He's on
ABC News and he said this is what
they're saying even though Jesus says if
somebody strikes you on the right side,
turn to them the other also. So how how
do I how do I do that? I think when when
you're talking to other people who are
martial artists and those that may be
watching it,
it's taken very personally.
>> Yes.
>> When you hear this kind of a program is
like, what are you telling me that I'm
supposed to stop?
>> Yeah.
>> That I'm supposed to quit? That I can't
do this anymore?
>> They're already defensive by nature of
the way that they're training.
>> Yeah. And for me, it's like, look, I'm
not I'm not saying anything.
>> It's God's word. I can't tell you to do
anything. I can't tell you how to to
live your life. I can tell you what
God's word says. And you have to
reconcile that with God. But you see the
that spirit of def self-defense
>> rises up, you know, like
self-justification, like you can't tell
me what to do. You can't tell me. And
I'm, you know, that's why I'd always
tell people, I'm not, it's not up to me.
You're the one that has to live your
life, but you're accountable to God's
word.
>> You know, do you know something that's
cool?
>> I remember when we first started putting
this film together years ago, and this
isn't about me or because I'm nobody.
I'm just dirt.
But when we first started putting this
together, and I had just met you, and
and Scotty and I had known each other
for a little while,
we had no idea the the millions of
people this was going to affect. And it
wasn't just about the martial arts. It
was about the miracle that God did with
my marriage. And
>> but even today, people are writing to us
or they're calling us and saying,
>> "I've been in martial arts." Like that
one lady I was telling you about, she'
been in martial arts for over 40 years.
And this is not she wasn't doing pancake
martial arts.
>> She was doing real serious hardcore
>> training fighting.
>> And she said, "I need to be free." I saw
this film and for the first time
>> questions that had been there in the
back of my mind for a while that the
Lord I'm realizing now it was the Lord
that was putting those questions there.
She said, "I asked him." She said, "I
was I was I was there and I was praying
and I was like, God, something's not
right and I don't know what this is."
And she said, "Help me to find it." She
said, "I got on the internet and boom,
the dragon revealed came up." And she
said, "And now she's free."
>> Yes.
>> After a couple of months of seeking the
Lord and and prayer, she's free.
>> You know what you just said holds all
the weight in the world, she was seeking
the Lord.
>> Yeah.
>> And Jesus tells us that we have to count
the cost.
>> Yeah. Amen. And he gives a requirement
and this is what grabbed me. He who will
come after me, let him deny himself,
>> take up his cross
>> and follow me. The first thing was to
deny the flesh.
>> Wow.
>> And the flesh naturally craves that
control
>> over your own life. Mhm.
>> And what I just saw in that clip,
um, our brothers there,
I don't think they're really
understanding that part, denying
yourself because you have to give up
something, something that's dear to you.
And what we gave up was dear to us. It
was not easy until we made the decision.
>> Yeah.
>> And when we finally made the decision,
God said, "Okay, I'll take it." But it
was when we were lingering. I know for
me when I was lingering and trying to
justify it was hard.
>> Yeah. I was riding that fence.
>> Riding the fence made it hard. But once
the decision was made.
>> Amen.
>> You know that speaks to what a gentleman
God is.
>> Yes.
>> And and how patient he is and he's going
to allow you to ask for that. Right. And
I I mean God wants to give us freedom,
right? He wants us to not be hurting
each other and and and living a life of
anxiety and, you know, fear and and all
those kind of things, right? He wants
you to be free from that. But it's like
he's such a gentleman. He's going to
wait till you ask. And just like that,
40 years somebody goes through that and
then finally it's just like, "Okay, God,
show me." And God goes, "Here, it's
right here." You know, I think we see
that a lot when you ask God. And and and
and that speaks to if you are a person
that's watching this and you've been
involved in this lifestyle and like
Keith said, you know, it's like your
first reaction is defensive like you
know what do you guys you guys are just
fanatics or or you know what what's
wrong with you? You know, you don't you
don't understand my way of thinking,
right? Doesn't matter what we all say.
Doesn't matter what we even think, but
it matters what God thinks.
>> And if you just take a second and just
go, God, is this something that you want
me to do? Mhm.
>> Is this something you want me to be
involved in? And listen to the way that
God answers that. You'll see
>> if we take a moment and we're, you know,
trying to be rational about it.
>> Honestly, can you
can you sit and say like, "Yeah, we're
going to totally be doing MMA in
heaven."
>> No. I mean, it's it's it's so
ridiculous. People will laugh at that.
Like they they smirk like, "Yeah,
right." You know, you and You
intelligently and intuitively know
that's not the case.
>> Yeah.
>> God
destroyed the earth because it was
filled
>> with violence.
>> With violence. So what makes us think
>> that we're going to a place where this
is going to be the norm? And if it's not
going to be the norm in heaven,
>> why would God want that now?
>> Amen.
>> Doesn't make any sense. The scripture
says uh backing up your point, Keith,
>> they will not hurt nor destroy in all my
holy mountain.
>> Amen.
>> And so if we're training to hurt and
destroy,
we're not training for that place.
>> That's right.
>> There's another uh verse here in 2
Timothy 3 verse 1-5. And the Lord is
speaking to each of us. You know, like
Scotty was saying, God has our best in
mind. He desires the very best for us.
He's not trying to take things away from
us because he doesn't want us to have
fun. He's trying to take things from
away from us that are killing us.
>> He says this, "Know also that in the
last days perilous times shall come for
men shall be lovers of their own
selves." That's what you're talking
about. I love I want to do what I want
to do and I don't want anybody to stop
me. M
>> they shall be covetous. They shall be
boasters. We just saw that.
>> They shall be proud. We saw that.
>> They shall be blasphemers,
disobedient to parents. Do you know what
we always put that and say, "Well,
that's the children." I I can skip over
that. Are you obedient to your parents
today?
>> Are you Do you honor your father and
mother? I'm 56 years old and the Lord
has convicted me in the last couple of
years. Eric, if you don't honor your
father and mother today, I'm not This
wasn't just for when you were five or
eight or 10. This is now,
>> even in the scriptures, you see the
patriarchs, even at 50 years old, they
still showed the greatest amount of
respect and honor for their parents.
>> They'll be unthankful, God says, and
unholy and without natural affection.
And we're going to see something about
that here in a few minutes.
>> They shall be truth breakers. Um there's
another word for that. It's covenant
breakers.
>> You know, your your marriage is a that's
a covenant not just with your wife, but
with you, your wife, and God.
>> They shall be false accusers. They'll be
incontinent. That means they won't have
any self-control.
>> They'll be fierce and despisers of those
that are good. They'll be traitors.
They'll be heady and high-minded,
lovers of pleasures more than lovers of
God.
>> And this specifically speaks about those
that profess Christ, but yet are living
the ways of this world. They have a form
of godliness. They have the shape of
godliness, but they deny the power
thereof.
>> The power of God is Christ and God
inside us.
not simply professing his name.
>> I'm going to show you a couple of quotes
from a a man named Kaia Green. He's a a
bodybuilder, a personal trainer, and
he's also fought in this quote one uh
MMA fight. He said, "Personally, I am
familiar with this feeling of rage and
aggression or what I call the animal
side." And I was very familiar with
those words because that's what was
involved in the type of kung fu that I
trained in. He said, "I use it to be
very free or I used to be very free with
this side and often times I would let it
come out in the wrong ways like stupid
street fights, drinking, hitting useless
objects, etc.
When I started training martial arts
seriously, the animal became more
controlled and buried. It had an outlet.
Do you know when I read this, the first
thing that I thought was the genie in
the bottle? You know, I go to this witch
or this witch doctor or this musician
and I say, "Look, I need some power."
And he says, "I've got a genie." And
you're like, "I want it. Give me the
genie." The genie's in the bottle. I can
call him out when I want him to and I
can put him back in the bottle when I
want him to.
>> That's a game.
>> The devil always says, "Oh yeah, I'm
here as your servant."
>> And then as you progress and as you
continue to open ground in your life to
that spirit,
>> pretty soon you find out the spirit is
pulling your strings. You're the one
that's being put back in the bottle.
>> A genie just got to throw this out here.
Um it comes from the root word jin. J I
N, which is basically a demon.
>> Yeah.
>> And um it's very interesting when you
when you hear that song that is is made
popular by the genie. Um you've never
had a friend like this, you know. And
that's exactly what it is is like I can
give you whatever you want. You're in
control. You do what you want. And
whatever you say, I'm going to give it
to you. You know, nowhere in the Bible
does God say that?
>> No.
>> No. No.
>> It's interesting thinking about all this
reminds me of
you know, just that spirit of pride
where
um is it Logan Paul and Mike Tyson
recently had a fight. Um
something like that. And I don't
remember how it came up, but you just
see how like nobody was going to back
down. You know, we're gonna do this
thing and nobody's gonna back down. It
didn't matter that Mike Tyson was like
31 years older than Logan Paul. It's
like, I'm not gonna back down. I'm a
fighter. I'm going for it. You know,
it's just interesting how that spirit
can continue to pervade throughout your
life if you let it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Listen to what he says. He
says, "The problem now is actually
bringing the animal back when it needs
to come back." For those who of you who
know, I've had one professional MMA
fight about this time last year. I lost
that fight. It was a great learning
experience and now I am accepting of
that loss. But I remember during the
fight one particular moment when the
animal came out. My point of this
message is that warriors as warriors we
need to be in tune with our animal, with
our rage, with our warrior spirit. We
need to be able to call upon it and
learn to use it. Most of you men know
exactly what I'm talking about. You've
had those moments of power of being on
the edge of control and yet loving it.
>> He's talking about when a demon is
influencing you and you do. You feel
like you're just on the edge where I'm
about to lose control, but you love it
because you love the feeling of power.
The scary thing is, you remember Robin
Williams talking about that? He said,
"When I'm up there acting on stage as a
comedian," he said, "you come right to
the edge, and sometimes I can cross that
line and come back."
>> So, it's like he's recognizing there's
something there, but instead of calling
it what it really is, an evil spirit, a
demon, a fallen angel, he's calling it
the animal. He goes on in the conclusion
and says, "When or if we ever have to
face a life ordeath situation, you need
to call upon your animal or the warrior
inside of you and use it to defeat your
adversary."
>> It's fascinating because they use the
same terms in uh Mortal Kombat,
>> you know, when they were tapping into
their animality or whatever in the video
game. It's that's each one had like this
spirit animal that they were supposed to
tap into and You could even see in the
animations for um
>> they're called a totem king or whatever.
It's like the spirit animal is a dragon.
And so you'd see
>> like whenever he'd do these certain
movements or you'd do these certain
combinations, this dragon would like
come out of him and like eat the other,
you know, combatant or stuff like that.
>> I do remember that.
>> Yeah, definitely. I mean, animality was
a as part of the movie series and part
of the video game series. They talked
about that. And and like in the ancient
cultures, even in South America, they
would channel animal spirits, not
realizing these are demons, but they
were, you know, the spirit of the eagle.
Native Americans did that. Yeah. And and
that was one of the and one of the
fighters in the Mortal Kombat series was
a Native American. And I think his
spirit animal was like a wolf. Mhm.
>> But you know, you think about um the
series um the kung fu series with David
Keredine, you know, how they showed how
you would be branded and depending on
what temple you went to, but the most
common ones uh you would be branded with
a dragon and a tiger when you pick up
the urn to leave the temple. And the
ones I think there were ones in Tibet
where it was a crane and a herring or
something like that. It was a little bit
different, but animals.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, and you're You know, as a
martial artist, you're you're kind of
ingrained with that idea of taking on
the spirit of the dragon.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, you want that that animal. You
want those movements. You want that to
become part of you and part of your
training. And
>> think about it a lot.
>> Yeah. Make a mental note of that because
that's interesting you brought that up
because here at the end, um, there's
going to be more light that's shed on
that. I'm going to show just some quotes
from some martial artists um to help you
understand because MMA is it finds its
roots in martial arts even though some
of the other uh violent sports like
football don't um many of the people
that are involved in it partake in it.
>> Yeah. But many many people who are
involved in things like football and
basketball and all that they train in
the martial arts. Many of them do.
>> Yeah. This is uh Master Nakayyama. He
was actually a grandmaster at 10th dawn.
He said, "The meaning of karate do goes
beyond victory in a contest of mastery
or self-defense techniques. The meaning
of karate dot hand. Unlike common
sports, karate do has a soul of its own.
>> To be a true master is to understand the
soul of karate do as a marshall way.
Forest E. Morgan who was a major in the
United States Air Force and he wrote a
book. He was also a martial artist.
Listen to what he said. The Marshall way
is a way of living. It is holistic mind,
body, and spirit. It is a holistic
holistic discipline aimed at the pursuit
of excellence. Not just in the training
hall, but at life.
>> It's disciples. That's funny, isn't it?
You know, Jesus had disciples,
they also have disciples. It's disciples
strive to apply quote the way. And he
capitalizes the word way.
>> Jesus is the way, the truth, and the
life. He's the only one that gets a
capital.
>> That's right.
>> He says its disciples strive to apply
the way in every vocation. This is what
separates the Marshall way from other
pursuits and makes it so valuable. where
one may play a sport or have a a hobby,
one lives the Marshall way. The Marshall
way does not start and end at the door
of the training hall. It is a way of
life in which every action in and out of
the training hall is done in the context
of what?
>> Warriorship.
>> Warriorship. Now, we're going to see
that many of these people that are
involved in these violent sports, that
violence is also showing up in other
ways and other areas of their life.
>> You familiar with the uh the newer film
Karate Kid Legends?
>> I I think I saw a trailer for it, but
yeah,
>> that's as far as it was.
>> Yeah, that's the Will Smith kid. No,
that's that one was about 10 years ago.
>> Okay.
>> The newer one, Karate Kid Legends, is
where
>> they they kind of pick up from that
story with the Milswie
Chan character who trains that kid.
>> Later on, they show him many years later
and he's he's still training and he's
training somebody else. And um that kid
winds up moving to the area and he
is going to enter a karate tournament.
So then they bring in Daniel Laruso, you
know, from the Karate Kid movies. Oh,
it's Ralph Machio, but they bring him in
to help with the karate aspect. But
while they're training, they're drilling
in into him's mind this the same kind of
idea like everything is kung fu or
everything is karate,
>> everything you do. And so even when the
kid is training somebody else who is a
boxer,
>> he's training him in kung fu. And he's
like, you know, when we roll out the
pizza dough is kung fu. The way we do
this or that or the other is kung fu.
Everything is kung fu. It's a whole way
of life.
>> You know, we actually practice that, you
know, um to make it real. Even the way
that you walk, the way that you turn a
doororknob to open the door,
>> it wasn't the usual wrist motion. It was
using the body to turn and to open. And
that was to sink the body in such a way
>> that you had the natural power of the
entire body. Not just the wrist or the
hand.
>> Not just the wrist or the hand. So that
now when you do a technique and it was
very effective, it's extremely powerful
and that's where the no or minimum
effort comes from.
>> And so drilling yourself in this kind of
thinking that also opens the door to the
philosophy that's taught. Mhm.
>> And it's a very ingenious, very subtle
way to open your mind to Eastern
philosophy.
>> Do you know what also is weird that just
just popped into my head from what you
said? It also engenders pride because as
you're learning this, I get more I get
more efficiency, more power by doing it
this way, using my whole body. The
common person doesn't know these things.
So they're still stuck doing the the
Goyam method.
>> Yes.
>> Do you know even children their parents
will take them to a karate studio or a
kung fu studio or taekwond do studio and
they say I want them to learn
discipline. I want them to learn
respect. I want them and you know what
after five years of being there the
child will come home and they'll lose
respect for their father and their
mother because my dad can't do the
things that I can do at the dojo.
>> It actually backfires.
>> Interesting. The word like it talked
there about the the context of
warriorship. Everything is done in the
context of warriorship. This is the what
the word budo actually means the the
Japanese or Okanawan term buddo. It
means the marshall way. The word bushido
which many people are familiar with in
iedo or in iikido um the Japanese arts
means the path or the way of the
warrior. Um, if anybody's ever seen that
film, uh, The Last Samurai with Tom
Cruz, and they showed it in there. You
look on the screen right now, there's a
samurai helmet, and you look and you go,
"What is that thing right on the
position of the third eye?"
>> The horns
>> right on the forehead. A
>> devil is a devil. Some kind of a dragon.
>> Angry devil.
>> This is where the seal of the living God
is supposed to be. The name of God.
>> Yeah. What that says is, and that's why
they would put that on their forehead.
>> Interesting.
>> That is where the power is coming from.
>> That is so interesting seeing that. I I
always noticed the horns, but I never
noticed
>> the face.
>> The the face.
>> Yeah.
>> And you know what it reminds me of? And
you'll remember this
>> in a dojo. All right. Traditional
teaching buddo or
>> bushidto you have the kamiza.
>> All right. And that is more like it's
almost like an altar.
>> Yes.
>> But it's taught that that is the seat of
the warrior spirit.
>> Yes.
>> So when we would go into the dojo first,
you know, you take off your shoes, you
bow
>> and you bow at the showman.
>> Yes. You come to the showman when you
start class, you kneel and then you bow.
You clap twice and you bow again. And I
remember asking what was the meaning of
the clap? It was to call attention to
the warrior spirit that you're ready to
begin and then it presides.
>> Oh wow.
>> Over the class.
>> Yes.
>> And so
but seeing that just brought that
forcibly back to mind. I never I always
saw the horns but I never saw the face.
>> Do you know what's weird when you said
that? And I know Keith you're familiar
with this.
Normally at the showman, which is the
the the head of the the room, the
training hall,
>> there's also a photograph of the
founder.
>> That's right.
>> And the master. That's the spirit that's
being passed down the line from the
founder. Even if he died 400 years ago,
the spirit that inspired him is passed
to the grandmaster now, who's passed to
the masters, who's passed to the
disciples, who's passed to the black
belts who are teaching our children and
our adults.
>> Yeah. And you're you're oftentimes told
stories about those people. You know,
they're they're highly revered
um for their capabilities and you know
accomplishments and so you're
>> you're finding yourself always wanting
to be like them.
>> That's true. Forest E. Morgan goes on
and says the true Buddo aspirant devotes
himself to a system of physical, mental,
and spiritual discipline. Mhm.
>> physical and mental. Okay, I understand
that he's talking about spiritual,
not just physical and mental through
which he attempts to elevate himself.
Where do we hear in the Bible about
somebody that wanted to elevate
themselves?
>> Nebuchadnezzar.
>> Nebuchadnezzar and Isaiah 14, Satan
said, "I will exalt myself, my throne
above the the stars of God."
>> That's right.
in in order to elevate himself in search
of perfection.
>> Martial arts are legendary for the
seemingly mystical powers they teach.
You will learn what forces warriors
really command. More importantly, you'll
learn how to develop them yourself.
That's what he puts in this book.
>> That's what we were taught.
>> Yeah. Because again, young, I remember
all of the things that my instructor
used to do and it became so common place
that the supernatural, even though it
still impresses you, it you're not
surprised by it anymore,
>> but you are chasing it. It's a reality.
>> It's a reality. You know it's true. You
see it all the time,
>> but you're chasing it,
>> trying to get to it. And sometimes I
think that it's purposefully difficult
just to pour pour gasoline on that fire
to make you strive even harder
>> and you're willing to do more to get it.
Thank God that he blocked me. Really
trying. He blocked me. So I never had to
experience a lot of things that I know
you experienced.
>> Do you know something that's
interesting? I remember and this this
man,
he was one of my best friends I've ever
had. and and we don't talk very often
because he's still involved in martial
arts heavy. He's been in it, you know,
now for he's probably been in it for
almost 40 years.
>> Oh, wow.
>> Um, but we were like best friends. I
mean, we would have given our lives for
each other. But I remember one time when
he introduced me to his grandmaster, who
was the last one that I trained under,
um that grandmaster could do things that
the former man that I trained under
couldn't. And I was like, "Okay,
obviously I need to move on. This is who
I need to train under." And I asked my
friend, I said,
"Can you tell me
something about what this man can give
me?" And and my friend Allan, he told
me, he said, Eric, he said one time when
he and I were alone, CJ Joe the
Grandmaster, he said he was a third
degree and he'd been training in energy
and chi and he said, I asked the
grandmaster, he said,
I've been doing for the last 12 months
what you have been telling me to do. And
he said, I still can't make the effect.
I can't do what I see you doing. Mhm.
>> And you know what the grandmaster told
him? He looked at him and he said,
"You're not willing to pay the cost that
I was willing to pay to get this kind of
power."
>> And I found out later where that was. So
>> this is the Grandmaster's text from
Geishin Fukushi. Um this is the artwork
on the cover of that book. And and I
know there's different variations of the
book, but when I saw the book because I
purchased it,
>> um I saw the cover and I looked at the
picture and I thought, man, that looks
like a demon. I mean, even though I'm in
the martial arts still, I was like,
"This looks like a demon."
>> Well, I looked up that image and I
looked up the story behind that image.
The Japanese call it audo moyo. It is a
It is a wrathful messenger. That's the
word for angel. A messenger. A wrathful
messenger. An Asian deity known as one
of the five wisdom kings.
>> This is where the power comes from. This
is the man that people will quote when
they talk about putting their children
in martial arts. Well, Geishim Fukushi,
he talks about martial arts is not about
compassion, competition. It's about the
perfection of character. And you're
like, have you seen the the the cover of
his text,
>> his Grandmaster's text? Romans chapter 1
28-32 says, "And even as they did not
like to retain God in their knowledge,
God gave them over to a reprobate mind."
That's to another mind
>> to do those things which are not
convenient, being filled with all
unrighteousness and fornication and
wickedness and covetousness and
maliciousness. Yay, full of envy and
murder and debate and deceit and malign.
They become whisperers, backbiters,
haters of God, despiteful,
proud, boasters, inventors of evil
things, and disobedient to parents
without understanding. They are covenant
breakers without natural affection.
Natural affection is not just the
affection between a husband and a wife.
It's the affection between a mother and
her children. How could how could
mothers abandon a child? or how could a
father abuse a child
>> without natural affection, implacable
and unmerciful? And then listen to this.
This is what caught me. It says, "These
people who knowing the judgment of God
that they which commit these kinds of
things are worthy to death. Not only do
they do the same things, but they have
pleasure in them that do them." That
means not only would I do it, but I'll
go pay money so I can watch somebody
else do it. Whether that be at the arena
or whether it be on Netflix or whether
it be on your iPhone, we're paying to
watch the things that will cause people
to lose eternal life.
>> So that means that then
those of us who take pleasure in those
that do the things which fall under this
category, whether it's fornication,
adultery, violence, etc., watching
movies or um participating in these
events, we are worthy of the same
condemnation as those who are doing
them. The same judgment.
>> That's right.
>> I want to show another clip here about
MMA. And this is a little bit different
because this this almost brought me to
tears. It was hard to watch, but it it
almost brought me to tears. Happening
today, ex UFC fighter War Machine will
learn exactly how long he's going to
spend behind bars. He was convicted of
beating up his ex-girlfriend, porn star
Christy Mack.
>> Yeah, Marissa Kennon joins us live right
now outside the Clar County Detention
Center with the latest. Marissa
War Machine has already spent some time
behind bars, but he could spend even
more. War Machine faces life in prison
after being found guilty of beating up
Mac and another man back in 2014. napped
after seeing her in bed with another
man. Max said the beating was so brutal
she had to be hospitalized.
>> What's up, gang?
>> This is the former US UFC president
>> Dana White.
So, I just wanted to come out today and
talk to you guys
uh on this media day with the athletes
that, you know, the focus is on them.
These guys have trained hard and got
ready for this fight. What happened uh
on New Year's Eve is mine, my mistake,
not theirs. And obviously
uh nobody's more about free speech than
me. If somebody if you know if one of
the fighters wants to come out and voice
their opinion on it and and uh whatever
it might be then then by all means I'm
sure you guys have seen the the TMZ
video and seen uh my interview. It was
obviously a horrible personal experience
and uh you know there's no excuses for
it. Something that I'm going to have to
deal with and uh live with for the rest
of my life. what what these men are
describing here has become rampant in
UFC and MMA.
>> They're talking about domestic violence.
I mean, like this is not an isolated
event. the the former president of UFC,
um Dana White, he was actually at a a
party at a club with his his girlfriend
and um actually no, it was his wife and
she had been drinking. He had been
drinking. They're in a club like you
were talking about in that other
program. You know, don't put yourself in
those bad positions.
Something was said and she slapped him.
And without even thinking, without even
thinking, and they had it on video,
somebody was recording it. He smacked
her hard, knocked her down. And you got
to think, he's a man that's been in MMA.
He's a fighter. He knocked this woman to
the ground with this one smack. And
you go, okay, that's an isolated event.
Well, then when I was looking online,
it's all over the news of multiple over
and over and over again. MMA fighters,
mixed martial arts fighters having
domestic violence, abusing their wives,
abusing their girlfriends.
>> So what happens is is the spirit that is
causing that violence, that pride, that
rage, that spirit of control, that
spirit of dominance, the spirit of of
I'm not going to back down from anybody.
I'm not going to be humiliated by
anybody. I'm not going to be humbled by
anybody. that falls even into marriages,
into the home. Um, and that that's
terrifying. And I'm I'm praying for for
this man because I mean, you could tell
I think he was really upset by what
happened.
>> Um, I I don't know his heart and his
life, but we need to pray that the Lord
will help him to turn to Jesus.
>> Yeah.
>> To see it's not simply, hey, I lost my
job. It's not simply I got to step down
from this. I need to seek help because I
don't want this ever to happen again.
Mhm.
>> And and we have talked about this. Some
of you guys have mentioned this earlier.
Galatians talks about these two
kingdoms, the two battles that are
happening. It says the work of the flesh
are manifest, which are these adultery
and fornication. And the word
fornication there in Greek is literally
porna. Um, and people will say, well, I
don't look at pornography. If you're
looking with lust at a Wrigley Spearmint
Gum commercial with women on the beach
in a bikini, it's pornography. Um, and I
know people don't like to hear this, but
I I tell my wife, I'm like, I'll go to a
beach if it's a private beach and I'm
clothed. I
If Scotty asked me to come over to his
house or you asked me to come over and
visit you or Keith and I showed up for
dinner and I'm sitting there in the
living room with you or in the dining
room with you and all of a sudden your
wife walks out in her underwear and her
bra and starts making dinner, I mean,
like, you would be appalled
>> and I would be embarrassed. I'd be like,
I' I've got to go outside. But yet,
we'll go to the beach and there's women
in less clothing than a bikini or less
clothing than their underwear. And
they're walking around and we like it's
okay because the tag says it's it's a
bikini. It's a bathing suit.
>> It's crazy.
>> It is.
So, it says the works of the flesh are
these uncleanness and that includes
physical and moral impurity.
Lasciviousness, that means looking with
desire.
idolatry, witchcraft. You know the word
witchcraft, its root word is actually
rebellion. M somebody that's practicing
rebellion against God, they actually
open the door to a spirit of witchcraft,
>> wrath and strife and seditions and
heresies, envys, envyings, murders,
drunkenness, revelings, that means to
party of the which I tell you before, as
I also told you in time past, they which
do such things shall not inherit the
kingdom of God. Mhm.
>> And then the Apostle Paul says, "But
the fruit of the spirit of God, the Holy
Spirit is love." And the word love
literally means to sacrifice yourself on
behalf of others.
>> If you really love me, are you willing
to lay your life down for me?
>> Joy, peace. None of the people that
we've watched so far had any joy or
peace. You look in their eyes, even when
they're smiling, there was no joy or
peace. Mhm.
>> When you just said love, could you
repeat that?
>> The definition of love,
>> the definition
>> we have in scripture, Jesus says there's
no greater love than this, that a man
lay down his life for his friends.
>> Love is sacrificing yourself on behalf
of others.
>> How do we see that in the UFC in a
match?
>> Yeah.
>> How do we see that in most of our lives?
It's just not even close.
>> How do you see the self-sacrifice then
on a football field between teams?
>> Yeah.
>> Because the nature of competition is to
subdue
>> someone else.
>> So that I can get
>> so that I can be on top. It's the
principle that's totally at odds with
that.
>> It's true.
>> And I want that spirit.
So, love, self-sacrifice, joy, peace,
longsuffering, patience. Your wife
smacks you and you go, "Honey, I mean,
what did I do? What's wrong?" And
there's no patience.
>> Gentleness, goodness, faith, believing
God's word,
>> meekness, and humility. I know when I
was in the martial, I still pray against
that. Even being in ministry, I'm like,
"God, don't let a spirit of pride." When
people will come up to me and say,
"Eric, that was a great message." I'm
like, "You have no idea." I couldn't put
two words together if it wasn't by the
mercy of God. Amen.
>> It's not me.
>> Temperance. That means even with eating
and other things. Temperance. Against
such there is no law. Why? Because they
that are Christ have. It's done.
Crucified the flesh with the affections
and lust thereof.
>> Hallelujah.
>> Amen. Now, I'm just going to close with
a couple of slides. I want to show you
something. When I was training under the
last Grandmaster that I trained under, I
remember he had a library. And
when you're when you're at certain
levels in martial arts, beginning
levels, you're very distant from the
Grandmaster or whoever the instructor
is, and as you progress and get higher
in rank, you get closer and closer to
him, which is interesting because that's
how the sanctuary service was. out here.
If you're a gentile, you're way far away
from the goal, which is God.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah.
>> This is a counterfeit.
He had a library. And I remember when I
went to visit him one weekend, uh he
invited me into his library and I was
like, "Wow, this is what I want to see.
I want to see what he reads and what
information he gets." And I found some
very interesting things in there that
I'm not not going to go into, but he
pulled one book off of the shelf and he
handed it to me and he said, "You need
to buy a copy of this." And this was the
cover of the book,
>> the Shaolin Grandmasters Text. And it
was written by Shaolin Grandmasters that
had fled China during the Cultural
Revolution.
>> And I understood after I got home why he
wanted me to read it. There's protocol
in there about a grandmaster and what
somebody that wants to be a master, what
you do and how you how you bring how you
bring up students under you. One of the
things I did not realize until I read
that was when you go to visit a
Grandmaster, every time you go visit
him, you're supposed to hand him an
envelope with a gift in it.
>> And that envelope has to be a red
envelope.
>> It can't be another color. H
>> anyway, first page. I got home and I
opened this book up to read it. First
page, opening page. This is what was on
the the opening page. The spirit of the
dragon dwells deep inside each of us,
waiting to reveal itself to those who
would have it come out. Wow.
>> And when I read that, it was like the
And I was still in the martial arts. The
hair on the back of my neck stood up.
The alarms were going off. God was
going, "Eric, run. Run. get. I know who
the dragon is. That's Satan. Revelation
12.
>> And I was like, and then I what I did
was the enemy was like, "Yeah, it may
mean that to them, but that doesn't have
to mean that to you." So, it's like I
squash that alarm and I said, "I'm going
to just take what I need out of the book
and I'm going to ignore the rest."
>> And then I went to see the Grandmaster
one day. Again, I had to travel about
six hours to train with him. And I know
I've shared this on some of our other
programs, but we may have viewers that
are not seeing this or this may be the
first time. When I went to train with
him, it was a one-on-one private class
and he and I are there just talking, you
know, just chitchat before we begin
training. And the door to the school,
the Dao Jang, opened up and this young
black belt came in. He was probably in
his late 20s, early 30s. And he had this
huge piece of artwork that was wrapped
up in brown paper and it, you know, had
twine wrapped around it like how they'll
do. And uh he said, "See Joe, see Joe,
they finished it. They finished it." He
was so excited. And then he set it down,
you know, the grandmaster pointed and he
set it down and then he stood there
because he wanted to see it.
>> And the grandmaster just looked at him
and nodded. And what I could look in his
eyes, I knew what that meant. It meant
go away. You know, you're not needed
anymore. And you could see the the
younger black belt. He was just like,
"Yes, sir." And he left. But he didn't
want to leave. So the grandmaster went
over and he opened this up. I'm going to
just call him Dana because I'm and I am
still praying for this man. But he
opened up, took that paper off it, and I
saw this beautiful piece of Chinese
calligraphy. And Japanese and Chinese
calligraphy is gorgeous. I mean, if
you've got somebody that knows what
they're doing because they use these
brushes and it makes the writing is just
gorgeous. There's a couple of symbols
that I knew because I just never was
interested in in speaking the language
or writing it. But this was a symbol I
had never seen before. And this is not
the actual symbol that I saw. I just had
to look for an illustration. I saw the
symbol and I was like, it's beautiful
artwork. I didn't say anything, but
that's what I was thinking. And I'm
looking at it and
>> Dana, my instructor, he knew what I was
thinking. And finally, I was like,
"Okay, I'm just going to ask." I said I
said see Joe. I said it's beautiful but
what does it mean? And he looked down at
the ground for a second and then he
looked up and looked straight in my eyes
and he said the easiest way to translate
this in English is this. It's the devil
that's in the details.
And
I mean, I was just like, you know, I
drove six hours home that day after
training and it was like I couldn't get
rid of that. I was like, look, and God
is up there saying, Eric, I love you.
I'm trying to set you free. I just gave
you, you can't ask for more of a witness
of who's behind what you're doing in the
martial arts.
>> It's the devil that's in the details.
>> He was not a He was not a Christian.
He'd been raised in a Christian home as
a boy, but he had been involved in
Chinese martial arts for his whole life.
I mean, over 40 years.
And he's telling me, "This is where the
power comes from." And I'll never
forget, you know, there was another
night where I was training with other
black belts and we got done training and
he asked us, "Hey, would you guys like
to stay? Let's watch a movie together
and eat." And you know, you never say no
when a grandmaster asks you to eat with
him. I mean, that's disrespectful. That
could cut you back another year on your
next rank. So everybody wanted to stay
and we're sitting up watching some dumb
movie eating pizza and
about 12:00 everybody's exhausted. You
could look in their eyes. They're all
exhausted. They can barely keep their
eyes open. And he starts talking about
the Illuminati and Freemasonry and all
the and it's like I woke up instantly
because I was like I I knew a little bit
about that stuff. So all of a sudden I'm
like okay I'm interested in this. and
he's talking and then right in the
middle of this talk after about 30
minutes everybody is like their frontal
lobe is shutting down because of
exhaustion.
>> He says, "Oh yeah, by the way,
you guys want to understand chi energy?"
He said, "Look at Jimmyi Hendris. Look
at Eric Clapton."
>> He said, "The power that they get to
write and perform is the same power that
you and I tap into in martial arts." And
I was in my head. I was like, "What?
Wait a minute. I didn't say anything,
but I'm like,
>> they don't train in martial arts. I
mean, to the best of my knowledge, how
can that be the same power?
>> And after the Lord revealed this to me,
I was like, that's the power they are
channeling demons to write the music and
perform. It's the same spirit that we're
t tapping into for the martial arts
power.
>> When I look at this symbol, it's the
devil that's in the details. All right.
Um, I know that in the Japanese martial
arts, um, one name for demon is an oni.
>> Yep.
>> All right. And there are techniques that
are named after this, like oni kodaki,
crush the demon's shoulder. It's a it's
a technique that dislocates the
shoulder. And I remember the instructor
that I had at the time, um, I remember
when we went through pain tolerance
training. Yeah.
>> And sometimes the best way to learn the
technique is to be the uk for the
instructor. And you learn things that
you normally wouldn't learn just by
watching. You can feel the details.
>> I remember one time he came in and um he
demonstrated a really really brutally
painful technique and taught it to us.
And we asked him how he learned that.
You know what he told us? He told us
that a number of nights before he had
gone out into the woods and he had a a
training partner
um and it wasn't a human training
partner
>> that taught him the technique and then
he showed the bruises on his body.
>> Oh wow.
>> And um that's the technique that he
showed us.
>> Yeah. And so I'd never known that, but
seeing that reminded me of that story
>> that for me what you just shared,
>> it's like God is confirming this. He's
telling all of us that are watching
right now, listen to what you're
hearing.
>> If you need more information, contact
Brother Christian. Contact Little Light
Studios. Watch the Dragon Revealed part
one and part two. There's lots of
information there. We have no idea what
we've been tapping into. Our last two
slides, Revelation chapter 18 verse 1
and two. The Bible says Babylon the
great is fallen is fallen. Babylon is
this world. It's this world system for
she has become the habitation of devils
and the hold of every foul spirit and a
cage of every unclean and hatefilled
bird.
And I heard another voice from heaven,
saying, "Come out of her, my people,
that ye be not partakers of her sins,
and that you receive not of her plagues.
For her sins have reached unto heaven,
and God has remembered her iniquities."
>> That is what God is calling each of us
as his sons and daughters. Come out of
this world. Be not partakers of this
world. For what fellowship does light
have with darkness? All
[Music]
right.